I started seeing this five-second window
everywhere everywhere in order to make
it stick
go brick by brick for a long time in my
life I started to think that luck was
for other people and the secret to life
and this is so hard to grasp is to just
be yourself
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one use the five-second rule if you're
in a situation where you should do
something and the excuses roll in you
only have five seconds before the
excuses win that's it and it has to do
with how your brain is designed and so I
started seeing this five-second window
everywhere everywhere you walk into a
networking meeting and the five-second
window is right there because you look
around and you see all these people you
should talk to and you feel yourself
freeze five four three two one and you
can start walking if you're trying to
sell something the five second window is
always there because you either have a
phone you need to pick up and make a
phone call or you have a person you need
to talk to but instead of doing it that
five second windows right there and the
excuses roll in and then you're not
doing it yep
and so I think we talked ourselves out
of it right after five seconds that why
not to do it all and then it's even more
sophisticated than that is which is what
I discovered and what's more
sophisticated about it is that you have
two modes to your brain you have the
prefrontal cortex which is the mode of
your brain it's the front part of your
brain that does all your strategic
planning your decision-making your not
only your decision-making that's wrong
it does your intentional decision making
conscious decision making it's what
you're using when you're acting with
courage it's what you're using when you
are learning anything new if you've ever
taken a standardized test when you walk
out of a standardized test what do you
have you have a freaking headache
because you've been using this part of
your brain that's the one part the other
part is the interior part of your brain
which automates everything it's where
self doubt is it's where habits are it's
where automated decision-making is it's
where every negative [ __ ] that we do
it's stuck right here so what the
five-second rule is actually doing on a
very sophisticated level is it's
switching off this part and awakening
the part that gives you control and so
the problem with our excuses if you want
to get into the brain science is that
you start to think and you start to
think I feel tired or I don't want to
wear I'm too stressed out or now's not
the right time that becomes automatic
and it gets encoded right here so part
of the problem with our excuses is that
when you stop and think and hesitate you
trigger your brain to automatically talk
you out of it that's the problem it's
not the excuses it's that your brain has
done it over and over and now it takes
over so I invented the world's most
powerful cheat code for the brain one
night when I was drunk
sitting in my living room watching
television also if you want to have more
confidence check in my 254 series
they're free the links are in the
description below if you didn't give
what anybody else thought what's the
thing you would love to be doing with
your life you might want to get honest
with yourself like instead of doing this
be a millionaire or do this
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
in order to get to the next level in
your business you got to decide right
now what habits do you have as a leader
that you have to change now
rule number two go brick by brick in
order to make it stick
go brick by brick in order to make it
stick go brick by brick one of the
things that's interesting about having
big dreams and big goals is that
oftentimes the fact that the goals and
the dreams that we have are so big it
makes them really really difficult to
achieve because you spend so much time
thinking about how big the idea or the
dream is that you become paralyzed in
the moment around taking action how do
you build a house by laying a foundation
brick by brick by brick you go one small
brick at a time and it's exactly the
same thing for your goals by the way so
if you think about where you're at in
this moment and you think about the path
that will take you forward to your big
dreams or should this change that you
want to make and
I'm gonna use the eating program is my
example because this is daunting to me I
can come up with a million reasons right
now just like I'm sure you can come up
with a million reasons why you can't run
a marathon you can't do the singing
telegram business you can't take nature
pictures for a living you can't be more
connected to your husband which is what
Leanne wants you can't launch that
aromatherapy business I can't possibly
do a structured eating program with the
scale right now because I travel too
much because I'm too busy because I'm
lazy because I'm not deliberate like my
bracelet remember my intent bracelet I'm
reminding myself to be deliberate which
is probably why I'm thinking about this
program the path between where I'm at
and where you want to get to is the same
it is a brick path and it is comprised
of a ton of little bricks that come
together to take me forward and so when
you think about a goal or you think
about a dream as a million little bricks
that come together and lay a path
forward that's the way visually you can
break down your goals and so for me you
know what that one brick could be today
it could be asking Chris or my
brother-in-law for the phone number of
the person not even making the call
people I'm talking about breaking
they're down to one brick so I will get
that phone number and I will write it
down in my little red book or I will
write it down and my five second journal
and that way I will have the number and
guess what the brick is gonna be
tomorrow the brick tomorrow is gonna be
to call the guy right and make an
appointment and then the next brick
might be to read a little bit and so the
key is going brick by brick to make it
stick because if you think you can lay
the whole path between where you're at
and where you want to go right now
you're nuts
rule number three make your own luck I
started thinking about luck because
there are for a long time in my life I
started to think that luck was for other
people that luck was just one of those
things that if you were lucky
enough to be born with luck you won the
lottery you got the job you wanted your
family got along and the truth is
there's a tremendous amount of science
behind life that luck is something that
you can make for yourself that you can
become luckier based on the things that
you do and the things that you think
about and one of the things about lucky
people is a lot of lucky people make
their luck because they have trained
themselves to think optimistically and
one small trick that you can use in your
life that is free you can do it today is
when you go to bed tonight before you go
to sleep I want you to write down one
thing that happened today that was good
that's it every night before you go to
bed I want you to write down one thing
that happened today that's good in fact
let's do it right now in the comments go
to the comments and tell me one thing
that has happened today that you can
think of that's good just one thing
maybe you got up on time maybe you
didn't have traffic today on the way to
work maybe you haven't fought with your
kids this morning maybe you got to the
gym maybe you woke up and for the first
hour of the day you didn't make yourself
wrong all of those things while they're
really little don't dismiss them because
those are things that are good and the
reason why I want you to start a
practice where every night before you go
to bed or if you don't want to do it at
night do it in the morning every night
before you go to bed write down one
thing that happened today that was good
the reason why you're doing this is you
are training yourself to start to spot
the good believe it or not training
yourself to start to look for the good
in your life fundamentally trains your
mind away from looking at
negative so that you start seeing this
thing that's positive about your life
versus that thing that's negative about
your life number four just be yourself
and the secret to life and this is so
hard to grasp is to just be yourself
that's the secret
there's only one you there's only ever
gonna be one you there's never gonna be
another you and the way you make your
mark in this world the way that you
learn how to believe in yourself the way
that you discover the people that you're
supposed to surround yourself with the
job that you or career path that you're
supposed to have is by being the real
you rule number five learn from every
experience now I got fired from a job I
was really excited about what should I
do
excellent question first of all how many
of you have ever been fired from a job
yeah yeah I have been fired from a job
and let me tell you something it's a
kick in the teeth doesn't it there's
nothing that feels worse in the moment
than being brought into a conference
room and being let go and then how bad
does it blow to pack up your stuff and
to leave its things it is terrible it is
humiliating there is nothing around it
there's nothing around that feeling even
if it's a job that you can't stand even
if it's a job where you've been looking
for another job
even if you know in your heart that this
is the biggest blessing in disguise
because you didn't really like it there
you still want to be the one
don't you want to be the one to walk in
and be like guess what people I found a
different job out again so when they
beat you to the punch and they tell you
the truth that this isn't working it's
not working for them it's not working
for you and now it's time for you to
leave it is still a kick in the teeth so
I want to be clear about something
feeling down feeling embarrassed feeling
angry about how it was handled even if
they handled it in the way that is legal
that's normal it's normal because it
blows to be rejected and that's exactly
what happens to you emotionally when you
get fired from a job I get that because
boy oh boy
have I been there I have been fired from
jobs that I actually liked I have been
fired from jobs that I needed and I have
been fired for jobs that I viscerally
hated that I was physically sick going
to work every morning I hated it so much
and it's still space when you're fired
so here's what I want you to do in your
fire I want you to really just relish
and how much it stinks for no more than
24 hours you get to milk this puppy for
free you know a free dinner from your
pals at night you get to milk this and
complain about it to all your friends
for 24 hours and then guess what you got
to stop complaining about it you got to
stop thinking about it because you don't
have a choice anymore the job is over
and I don't want you looking back I want
you looking forward now before you look
forward though I want you to do one of
the signature things that we talk about
all the time and what is that I want you
to look for the mess
in the mess what is it that you learned
about yourself or about a job or a boss
or a or a kind of work that you need to
make sure you understand the message of
the mess because when you get the
emotion out of the way guess what you
always see about a job or a breakup that
happens you always see that that was
exactly what was supposed to happen that
that job that that person that that
manager that that focused that that was
holding you back and you were just too
scared to take the leap you were too
worried about finances you were worried
about how it looked I've been there I
get it but you need to see the message
in the mess because I don't want you to
make the mistake and step into the exact
same thing or the exact same type of job
or the exact same management situation
that didn't work the first time because
part of the reason why jobs don't work
is it's not a fit you see people get
fired for a lot of reasons some of the
reasons why people get fired is because
the companies are not doing well and in
that case you want to thank your lucky
stars that you're getting out now so
that you can find something better if
it's not a fit that's a more nuanced
reason to get fired but let me tell you
some if it's not a fit for the company
it wasn't a fit for you either and so
look for the message in the mess what
are you gonna learn about this situation
whether there was a skill gap and you
need to bring your skills up to speed so
that you're not floundering your next
job or maybe it was a personality gap
that you accepted something
in your hurt you knew wasn't right but
you took it because you had to or
because you felt insecure don't make
that mistake again
rule number sixth used a 90 seconds rule
you know that um wave that you feel or
your tongue gets numb or you get
tightness in your cheeks or you freeze
you know when that happens based on the
science there is only a 90 second
chemical release in your body it's
called the 90-second rule when your body
starts the stomach starts to flutter
when your heart starts to raise when you
feel this feeling of fear that you have
that's unique to you
based on the science there's a 90-second
role and all of the chemical release
that's happening because your body is
going into a state of being alert it
only sticks around for 90 seconds as
long as you don't let your thoughts race
if your thoughts start to race you'll
start to agitate the situation so the
next time that your body goes into a
state of alert stomach gets tight you
feel frozen you get stock you feel your
neck when the body starts to do that
number one just remember it means your
body is getting ready to be alert and
pay attention doesn't and it does not
mean you're gonna lose control it does
not mean you're in danger it does not
mean to stop or to shut up I want you to
take a deep breath count to 5 5 4 3 2 1
that's it and realize that the hormones
that just got released because you're
about to do something they're only last
90 seconds that's it you can breathe
slowly you can count to 90 you can get
up and walk around you can do 90 seconds
of jumping jacks you can meditate for 90
seconds you can ground your feet in your
chair and wiggle a minute so that you
feel your body in your chair and take
deep breaths and what you're going to
find is that you're going to be blown
away you're going to be blown away
because what you're going to see is that
in 90 seconds flat you can go from being
somebody who has an upset stomach and
who would normally not go talk to your
boss who would normally not walk into
that gym who would normally not make
that call in 90 seconds flat you can
manipulate your body state to calm down
and you will notice that your thoughts
do not race your thoughts calm down
you're in full control and now you can
speak up and now you can show up li
number-7 expect a no the truth is if you
want control in your life if you want to
make things happen you have to be able
to expect that you're gonna get a no and
do it anyway so what do I mean when I
say if you want control expect to know
well there's a couple things that I mean
by it number one if you're somebody that
gets paralyzed because you want things
to be perfect perfectionism is a way
that most of us try to handle or
mitigate or make sure that we don't hear
no we assume that if we're perfect
everything's gonna go okay and so we
spend all of our energy thinking about
our dating profile or thinking about the
business plan or thinking about how to
make things perfect and the reason why
we do that is we're terrified to hear no
we're terrified to put something out
there that's not perfect because if it's
not perfect you might get an O one of
the better ways to handle this is to
actually expect an O you know I saw the
most incredible quote by our friend
Faustina over in Australia she's very
famous VJ and friend of ours from
Australia and she put out the most
amazing quote and I'm gonna get it
totally wrong but it's something like
this you have to be yourself because how
else are the people who are looking for
you gotta find you and I think
particularly when it comes to dating
what we tend to do is we are so afraid
of being rejected by anybody out there
that we try to be somebody that we're
not that we put out a fake improved or
what we think is improved
version of ourselves in order to not
hear no and most of us pretend to be
somebody that we're not when we fear
rejection when we believe that how we
are who we are isn't good enough and so
that's why it's so important for you to
understand that you have to be willing
to hear a no you have to be willing to
hear a no from the wrong people so that
the people that are looking for you can
find you so that the people who want to
be part of your business
can be part of your business if you're
putting a fake person out there or a
pretend perfect person out there because
you think that's gonna that's gonna save
you from rejection you're actually
screwing yourself over rule number eight
follow energy here's your new definition
of passion passion is simply energy
that's all that it is okay
passion is what you feel when you are
energized and excited about what you're
doing okay I want you to think about
that for a minute I want you to think
about a moment in time when you felt
incredibly passionate about something
okay and why don't you in the comments
tell me where are you watching from and
tell me about a moment in time when you
felt incredibly passionate about what
you were doing about where you were
about the people that you are with
describe that moment for me because when
you start to really investigate passion
as energy this is what you're going to
discover those moments when you are
super passionate like I'm sure my kids
would write down when they're doing
community theater with all their friends
I would write down whenever I'm doing
any kind of creative project with my
team I'm incredibly energized whenever
I'm doing group exercise stuff climbing
a mountain doing a 5k race doing some
sort of walkathon I'm incredibly
energized by that whenever I'm doing
some sort of creative project incredibly
energized by that whenever I'm working
with our video team incredibly energized
by that whenever I
I'm coaching someone or giving advice I
am incredibly energized by that and so
what I want you to understand is that if
you look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt passion I'm
being very deliberate and how I'm
talking this morning on coffee talk
because passion is a huge topic for so
many of you and you've been so focused
on trying to figure out what job is
gonna make me passionate what job is my
passion what is my purpose on the earth
I'm gonna tell you what your purpose on
earth is right now your purpose on earth
is to figure out how to align your life
so that you feel more energized and
excited by it that's it and it begins
with you following the energy and
following your natural enthusiasm you're
not gonna think your way to passion you
can't think your way to finding
something that you feel in your heart it
doesn't work that way
you got to feel your way into it it's
inside of you do you understand there's
no passion out there somewhere the
passion is in here and so what you have
to do first is you've got to stop
thinking that you're gonna find it
somewhere and you've got to realize that
passion is about unlocking something
that's already in you rule number nine
reset your mind set my mind can be my
worst enemy I was laying in bed last
night
and I had fallen asleep and I kept
waking up and you know what I was
thinking about I was waking up because I
could hear people in the hallway kind of
coming in from a late night up hurting
and you know what the first thing that
my mind defaulted to there being a fire
in the hotel and I started having these
visions of my daughter and I going down
the stairwell and getting trapped and
then I had visions of us being on the
balcony on this room and Fire kind of
engulfing and what are we doing or
retiring a rope wish I mean it's just
insanity absolute insanity and I I used
the techniques that I teach you I went 5
4 3 2 1 I am NOT thinking about this and
the thought disappeared because I
constantly reset my mindset and you know
one of the reasons why I'm telling you
that
as if you are tired of feeling negative
if you feel often that your own thoughts
are the things that trip you up in life
that you wish that your mind were more
positive I'm telling you that I'm the
same way
just because I teach this stuff just
because I study this just because I do
what I do for a living doesn't make me
immune to what it means to be human and
what it means to be human is that your
brain and your body want you to survive
your brain and your body
remember situations that scare the
daylights out of you your brain and your
body try to talk you out of anything
that makes you feel risky and your brain
given that it has been trained by
situations in the past and given that
you allow it to worry all the time you
have a habit of doing it if you're not
careful and you're not deliberate your
brain will default to scary crap like
mine was last night
that doesn't mean you're broken it means
that your brain is thinking something
that's broken and it's time for you to
reset your mindset and pull it back
I'm rule number 10 the last one for a
very special bonus clip is make sure
that your achievements are known do you
know what the one strategy one strategy
that is associated with making more
money for women do you know if there's
what is one strategy that will help you
make more money as a woman when you work
in a company
you can put it in the comments you can
guess I know it's not working longer
hours no it's not taking the notes in
the meeting no it's not doing everybody
else's work for them the one strategy
based on research that will actually
translate to you making more money is
making sure your achievements are known
and I wanted to deeper into this because
there are two kinds of work right two
kinds of work I want you to shift your
paradigm and the way that you think
about work because you do two kinds of
work you do work that is visible and
that is the work that you get credit for
so visible work consists of the ideas
that you share in a meeting it consists
of the things that you talked to your
boss about it consists of the work that
you're doing that people see it consists
of the results that you generate that
are reported and discussed and most
importantly it consists of the projects
that you are working on that are
strategically aligned with the goals of
the company that people know about
invisible work on the other hand is all
the stuff you don't get credit for so
all those folks that you mentor in
private you're not getting credit for
that you should still do it but I'm
going to tell you how to do it
differently answering the same question
over and over and over again for
multiple people on telephone calls
that's invisible and if you only make
one change this year in your career I
want you to take on a habit of making
sure your accomplishments are known
that the things that you're doing are
more visible now I have a special bonus
tip from Mel and how to find what works
for you that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one where do
you need to follow the energy in your
business number two what's the mindset
reset that you need to take and number
three what are you procrastinating on
that you can apply the five-second rule
to and if you like this video and will
take action after watching it give me a
hash tag believe down the comments as
well at the end of the day I'm giving
you advice I am sharing research with
you I am telling you what works for me
and what works for thousands of people
around the world but here's the deal you
got to take all this advice and you got
to pull it against your own personal
situation your own personal psychology
your own personal circumstances and you
got it you got to do what's best for you
because I can tell you to quit your job
because then you're gonna find a lot
more time to look for a new job and you
can use the 40 hours a week or 50 hours
a week that you were spending in that
crappy job that was sucking your life
dry and you can use all that time to
look for a job but here's the deal
you're the one that has to deal with the
financial stress so don't you dare take
any advice for me if it doesn't fit your
life I'm gonna move this way because the
windows are making the broadcasts a
little blown out do not take any and do
not take advice black and white until
you apply it to your own life because I
don't have to live with the
circumstances that you're living with
if you want more Mel Robbins check of
the top 50 rules video I made on her the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
our minds are designed to stop you at
all costs from doing anything that might
hurt you